we've got 1 million Premier League
seasons so what's happened is me and we
may Adam we've got together and we've
come up with a mathematical model and
we've simulated 1 million seasons in the
English Premier League which is the
Football League that we have here in
England just to see what happens
basically ok so for those that you don't
know this is how the the Premier League
works it's the top flight of English
football or soccer as a Americans like
to call it and basically there are 20
teams everybody plays each other
home-and-away and if you win the game
you get 3 points if you draw you get 1
points if you lose you don't get any
points it basically just taught up the
points and see who's got the most point
if there's any sort of ties or some
teams have the same number of points
there's no playoffs or anything like
that it goes down to something called
goal difference
which is basically you take the number
of goals that a team is scored and take
off the number of goals they've conceded
after that you go it goes on goals
scored and after that it's just they
just agree a tie
there's no ranking and you can actually
have literally two teams with identical
records in principle and literally they
won't be ranked they'll just say well
equal
[Applause]
obviously the goal is to is to win win
the championship but it's also really
important to get into the top four
because the teams to get into the top
four they go and so there's something
called the Champions leave the next
season which is really lucrative loads
of money the big thing you want to avoid
is relegation so that's finishing in the
bottom three if you finish in a bottom
three you actually drop down to the
division be loads of the league below
the subsequent season and that's really
bad because obviously it's nowhere near
as glamorous far less income all
together a whole lower standard of
football and you don't want to be there
basically so that's the thing to avoid
so football fans everywhere you know we
like to argue about you know how many
points do you need to win the league for
example I mean that's that's a big issue
this season because you know there's two
teams that I've got really great records
they're Liverpool and Manchester City
and it looks like you're gonna need a
lot of points to win the league this
season it's a thing you can ask normally
how many points would you need to win
the league how many points do you need
to guarantee entry into the Champions
League the next season to finish in that
top four and of course the one that
people really worry about is how many
points do you actually need to avoid
relegation what people talk about the
magical forty point mark so this is why
we got interested we were interested in
asking these questions from a
mathematical point of view so of course
we could answer some of these questions
theoretically but in not very
interesting way so for example if you
get 64 points you're guaranteed not to
be relegated that's a fact right you can
show that quite easily but of course
anybody gets 64 points or 63 points
actually is not going to get relegated
in any reasonable season so we wanted to
think more about probabilities and what
you know what's likely to happen but
mathematically that's pretty much
impossible to do what we call
analytically so you really have to run
computer simulations use this idea of a
Monte Carlo simulation you use sort of
randomness to sort of try to create
random seasons and then over a lot of
seasons the sort of probabilistic
scenario sort of play out this idea of
Monte Carlo simulations they go back to
the atomic bomb actually so we had a bit
of a journey in building up building our
model we started off with some simpler
models and then developed a quite
sophisticated one which is kind of based
on the kind of thing that bookmakers
used to predict outcomes of games we use
something called a Poisson distribution
to sort of get the expected goals we
said a given team would have in a given
game and built the model from that and
that used data from from last season's
Premier League actually it's kind of a
weird season in as much as Manchester
City had an anomalously good season they
got 100 points we're at the mercy of
that but we had to use something and we
literally played out the games in the
simulation so we did it as I said 380
games over a season a million seasons it
is quite quick I mean I'm not going to
take the credit for this I'm sure if I
wrote a bit code that tried to do this
it would take forever but my friend Adam
is much better at that sort of thing
than me and was able to write a very
efficient code which did it in about 20
minutes half an hour or so and so we
were really able to go out some fun
statistics out of it basically how many
points you need to win the Premier
League on average based on this
simulation well it turned out of the
mean number of points that finish second
place was eighty five point two so
basically that's telling us that you if
you get 86 points chances are you gonna
win the league in reality you know the
team winning the league was getting 95
points or so in this simulation again
that's because city did so well our
season and we were using last season's
data to get the Champions League for
example on average you would need 72
points according to this simulation
which is a reasonable figure there are
some circumstances where you would you
would need a lot more or a lot less but
that was generally the ballpark now the
crunch to avoid relegation well we can
look at the at the number of points on
average scored by the xviii team so
that's the the top team that did get
relegated and they got 32 and a half
points was the mean so that basically
means that 33 points should be enough to
avoid relegation based on the sort of
the simulators you would get from from
from last season's there that's quite
low I think that's bit on the low side
but again you know if you've read
averaged over more seasons with our
datum probably we would have maybe got a
higher figure there
so over a million seasons what sort of
things happened so for example what's
the most points that somebody won the
league with needless to say Manchester
City did honour on actually on 62
occasions
score 114 points which is where they won
every single game so 62 times out of a
million season the city got you know got
all the points that were available the
highest number of points somebody got
relegated with okay that would be a
disaster right you could get relegated
on a large number of points actually it
wasn't that high in these simulations
the highest number of points somebody
got relegated within our million seasons
was 44 and actually that's that's kind
of close to the sort of Premier League
data West Ham went down on 42
[Applause]
there was a season when teams played a
few more games where Crystal Palace went
down on 49 which was considered the
ultimate disaster so in the million
seasons there weren't any cases really
where a team got relegated having a
really good season yeah no not really
so other things that you notice the most
number of goals scored by a team in a
season Manchester City on one particular
season scored a hundred and sixty-one
goals which blitz is the the actual
record was set by Aston Villa in 1931
where they scored 128 goals again that
was in 42 games somebody actually won
the league in this as well
only scoring 50 goals obviously Man City
did annoy me well of the 1 million
seasons they won the league nearly 900
thousand times they won at eight hundred
ninety six thousand three hundred and
thirteen times actually the team that
won the next most this is kind of
curious you probably would think given
that we were basing our last season data
that the second-place team from last
season which was Manchester United would
win the next most that's not what
happened the team that won the next most
kind of pleases me was Liverpool okay
who finished fourth last season they won
the league in this 45 thousand eight
hundred sixty-two times out of our
simulation so the reason a model favored
Liverpool was because when they won
games they won by a lot they scored a
lot of goals they won spectacularly when
they won last season so the model Canada
likes that over the million seasons in
your model was there a freak season like
the famous Leicester season where it
where an underdog came through and won
so not really okay so no you're not in
the model simulation I'm talking about
here we did do a trial simulation where
Lester and it was Lester actually won
the league three times out of a million
in this simulation is sub maim on the
final one nobody outside of the top six
won the league nobody it's kind of
pressing actually did any of the big
super teams did yes yes this is quite
funny actually
Chelsea poor old Chelsea got relegated
five five times they finished second
from bottom twice and they finished
third from bottom three times none of
the other big six got relegated there
are a few sort of anomalous things Sam
Hampton did surprisingly well they
finish second once and they got into the
Champions League get this they got into
Champions League 22 times out of a
million okay which is rigged and they're
completely anomalous there's like nobody
else sort of that far down the table
does anything like that well again it'll
be because of the nature of it how their
games played out they've probably scored
if they score plenty goals that kind of
thing so there's sort of a general
overview of the season later but there's
some more fun extreme sitting in there
which we've got to talk about what's the
biggest win that anybody had in our
simulation in our million seasons well
needless to say it was Manchester City
and they beat Bournemouth 20 goals to
[Applause]
120 goals bombers got one that's blow it
out of the water the sort of the kind of
thing we've actually seen in real life
and the record score in a top-flight air
game is 12 nil and done by West Brom
over 100 years ago also Notting forest
did it over 100 years ago
[Music]
but over the course of a million years
it's reasonable that it'll happen one
day it is it is I mean it's not so crazy
that's sitting my occasioning get those
those kind of score lines over a million
seasons absolutely not
there are even more other remarkable
score lines Everton seem to be heavily
involved in some it's some crazy score
lines the highest number of goals by a
losing team ten chelsea played Everton
at Goodison Park Everton won 1110 okay
so that's a quick n Evan seems to be
involved in a lot of these games there
was a Merseyside derby which was the
highest scoring drawer that was Everton
nine liverpool nine i don't think my
heart would be able to cope with a game
like I wouldn't see limp 11 play and it
was a for all draw and that was bad
enough nine all I don't think I could
handle
[Applause]
the most goals in a game okay so the
most goals in a game that was Manchester
City beat again Everton 17 5 22 goals in
that game that's see that the record in
English football that in real English
football not in our simulation there was
trauma Rovers Tranmere be Oldham 13 4 so
17 fives not actually that far away if
you think about it you know the models
not perfect one thing it doesn't do very
well for example is particulars the
reason for that is because they're nil
nil drawer is it's kind of could be kind
of a game of attrition we you know once
a team gets sort of set in like that
then that dictates what happens next and
the model doesn't do that because it's
really really about randomness okay so
it doesn't really capture nil nails very
well so that's one of one of the
weaknesses of it and actually it's not
really clear how you would fix that's
tricky
[Applause]
you